le black friday très peu pour eux les
cartons c'est surtout pour faire passer
un paquet de revendications et mettre
les députés au pied du mur de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat si
le moratoire demandé sur la création de
nouveaux centres commerciaux semble acté
par le gouvernement ce dernier
encouragerait néanmoins la construction
d'entrepôts géants destinés au
e-commerce nous allons demander à nos
députés de ne pas être complice de cette
mascarade
nous leur demandons dans la loi climat
qui va sortir qui va être étudié au
printemps 2021 nous leur demandons
d'avoir le courage politique d'abord de
au bas mot voter ce moratoire et nous on
va aller plus loin on veut arrêter de
l'extension de ses entrepôts de
e-commerce qui sont désastreux au niveau
environnemental au niveau social au
niveau fiscal s'il écrit qu'il sera
vigilant quant aux textes de loi eric
alauzet n'en déroule pas moins une
palette d'arguments plutôt favorable au
e-commerce dont son leader est symbole
incontournable
amazon un géant dont la possible
implantation sur l'ancien héros parc de
fontaine fait débat farouchement niée
par la mairie de belfort et par le
principal intéressé
la future installation ne fait aucun
doute pour nos confrères de factuel qui
explique en avoir trouvé la preuve sur
les annexes d'un permis de construire
mal caviardé le non dissimulé par un
casque blanc apparaîtrait grâce à une
recherche d'occurrence et un simple
copier coller amazon serait bien à la
tête du projet citadelle une aubaine
pour l'emploi selon le discours
classique faux rétorque que les
militants altermondialistes occupé à
condamner les quasi orange d'un modèle
économique qu'il rejette en bloc
amazon depuis 2012 ses 81 mille
suppressions d'emplois qui ont eu lieu
indirectement par des petits commerces
qui s'effondre etc etc on en prévoit une
étude de deux économistes est sorti
aujourd'hui qui en prévoit 61 milles
d'ici 2028 si rien n'est fait malgré
cela plus d'un français sur deux achète
sur amazon encouragé par la fermeture du
petit commerce pendant le confinement la
tendance deviendra-t-elle une habitude
la balle est aussi dans le camp de
citoyens